yeah i'm ju i'm jumped up
i'm jumped up man
i got a frog in my bog right now i've
been having me a little bit of coffee
that um what kind do i have folgers
pecan praline flavor and damn boy
that [ __ ] got some whoo that it's got at
least some 84 octane in it that thing
oh give me heart gas bro you ever get
that
i used to get that when i used to work
out on a farm out there off of um
near the levee over there in mississippi
and i used to work on a farm over there
with a tall man and
and a fat fella kind of smaller and um
one of them died actually one of them
got on pills and died but
uh or not he didn't die but he did die
he did die but um oh [ __ ] what was i
talking about
oh i don't even know i do not even know
but um but i'm back and i hope you're
back
and apparently you are here we go
crowds of people turn to stare
there's nothing left to say
you
[Music]
by
this yourself there's no danger
[Music]
cause you found someone else
oh try to phase out better let me try to
phase out again
[Music]
yourself okay
and we are happy to have that music
right there and that is music by a
talented man
a man of talent named stevie starlight
and you know some of his music has been
with us since the beginning
since the beginning and that is off of
his new album
unnaturally happy and there will be a
link in the bio you can go and support
him
and um and thank you stevie for those
new tunes
thank you for that
good to be back i'm at home again i'm at
home again i like being at home
you know i i um i just moved the podcast
the episode back here
into my apartment i just
you know i don't know i just feel better
i feel
uh the bells and whistles sometimes
you know it's almost like say you go to
a christmas party
or if somebody has a party at christmas
and you go to that
you know what i'm saying say you walk
into somebody's house and people are
drinking eggnog and it's december
you know i don't know how else i can
explain it to you
but um and so and your wife or somebody
a man if you a gay man you got a buddy
or something you say oh that's my friend
carl or whatever
just my friend tyson but you always just
pretend it's your friend from the gym
but it's
you know it's gonna probably be your
husband if you guys live in a state that
allows it and you go in there and you're
wearing something that just
it doesn't you know you might be wearing
a christmas sweater but it's got the
the lights strewn into it and
you gotta carry a little can of um
you know electricity electricity little
generator
generator and you gotta plug it into
that and hold that [ __ ] all night and
you know and every you know every 30
minutes your sweater lights up and sings
you know
this is just my friend carl you know
that kind of [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying is that you might not feel
comfortable in it
you know in the beginning you'll like it
you'll like the
the fashion you'll like the
the the attraction people will come and
look at it
and they'll watch it play the song one
time or something
and maybe it'll give you a little you
know a hug or a pat on the back or
something
and be like oh what what gym do you guys
work at knowing that you guys live
together they're
you know everybody's playing along you
know then
and obviously you guys are you know
lovers probably
men lovers they call it some places or
whatever it doesn't matter
it could be your wife if you have a wife
it could also be your wife or whatever
what i'm saying is sometimes you're
wearing something that
you know it just it feels fun but it's
not
you know you just don't feel comfortable
in it
and um so anyway that's just how i've
been feeling at the
with the studio and so i'm just happy to
be uh
in my apartment there's
there's less expectations that maybe i
don't know what there are
i don't know and it doesn't matter maybe
i just feel good about it
um what's going on oh
i just got back from new
hampshire
live free or die that's their motto
up there and it's nice and you get up
there and you really can
feel you know you just
they got uh well i'll tell you what
happened i flew into maine
i flew into maine
you know and um in maine i don't know if
you've been to maine
i don't know if you've been i flew into
portland maine and if you've been to any
city or town up in this area in that
high new england
in that far reach of you know this is
the damn
this is this the seventh appendage bro
when you get up there way up off of main
and
in new hampshire some of that area you
just you don't know what's going on
really
you know there's still pilgrims parking
their boats there's
you know that you'll see a cannonball go
through the air it's they got some old
school
[ __ ] um
but they'd also the zoning apparently
here's the thing three things that are
allowed up in that area
dunkin donuts urgent care
and cemetery
those three things every other
area or building which is like a squaria
basically is one of those three things
do you go to don't you go to urgent care
what happened
oh he broke his arm oh give him a uh
give him an apple fritter you know oh a
shark bit off his uh shoulder
oh tape a kreller just you know
rubber some in a crawler up into there
and in a socket he'll be fine
doesn't matter you go get a blood
transfusion they'll [ __ ] pump you
full of
you know eight ounces of hot bavarian
cream just fill you up
that you know you get part of your spine
taken out it doesn't matter
they'll put two donut holes in there and
now you got a little sugar in your step
you know now you meet
men on accident it's just that i mean it
just those are the only
if you've been in this area those are
the only businesses
are you hurt if so
you might need a dunkin donut boy and if
not
you might be dead those are the options
urgent care dunkin donut cemetery
or cemetario bro that mexican death spot
you got
it so that's it up there
oh a bald eagle [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
your neck open
don't even worry about it bruh we'll
we'll frickin duct tape an eclair to
your cousin
you're gonna be fine it don't matter
the guy i mean they'll have a dead dude
they'll have somebody climb out the
grave and they give him a [ __ ] donut
hit him with two dunkin donuts bro he's
back it lays goes back to you know
the other side it's just that kind of
area there
it's just it's just so damn duncan and
it's just so damn urgent
and it's just so damn
deadly but that's the kind of place it
is live free or die
you know eat donuts
get urgently cared for and then go to
heaven
that's what they're doing up there so i
flew in
and uh oh and i went to see my buddy
and he is a you know this is a friend of
mine and we used to live together i just
actually sleep under his bed when i
first moved to um
los angeles when i first came out here
to this
city um
i slept under my my buddy kevin's bed i
slept under there for 150
and his roommate worked at tsa security
airport
and he had just gotten out of the
marines or double marines or something
or just i don't know he might have just
gotten out of the damn angry [ __ ]
club but he made me uh
one time i came home i don't know if you
would call it home when you're sleeping
under somebody's bed for 150
but you know i came back to the area
that i would
sleep under somebody's bed in and uh
and the roommate had my prescription
pills out at the table
you know because i was on a couple
things at the time you know
something for the brain something for
the pain you feel me i was on a couple
of uh
you know nothing crazy just some
antidepressants and maybe some
couple of percocets or some zany's
something
you know a little bit of stool softener
a little bit of stool hardener
and um and he sits me down at the table
and he had a damn pistol there and he's
like are these your pills
like he was just practicing he just got
a job working at the uh
you know it's doing i don't know
i don't know what he was doing but but
he had a weapon and he sat me down he's
like you could i could go to j these are
schedule one narcotics boy
i don't know what the hell like what
but um anyway so my friend kevin that's
who i whose bed i slept under
oh and i'll tell you this they had a guy
who lived with us years later and he was
a
this guy was uh you know he was black
and white swirled they used to call it
swirl
and he was swirl you know swirl but you
know a swirl boy and he um
he could jump over uh a volkswagen
and he was also he was on the olympic
junior ski team
or not ski but uh jumping
what's that sport where they jump across
the thing they just jump they spin in
the
you know they play a song and they jump
and they jump around and everybody tries
to pretend they're straight and it's all
in the end it's a lot of closeted man
but beautiful but the whole thing is
damn beautiful looks french kind of
but it's on ice you know what i'm
talking about anyway
i'm rambling but uh damn this coffee's
got me
um what am i talking about
uh oh so anyway my buddy kevin
now was up in new hampshire i went to
visit him
he's up there with his girlfriend and he
thought
she thought he was gonna surprise her
with marriage proposal
so she's expecting that surprise and
instead the surprise was me that i was
coming to visit so
it was not they were not enthralled she
was not enthralled about that
when you expecting that diamond ring but
you get the rat
king baby uh
so needless to say it was it was awkward
um but it was fun man and it was just
nice up there you know
they have lakes up there they have
a lake you know this where they have
crystal lake purity like the area we
were in
and beautiful just the kind of water you
just
got it feels like it has just like uh
amniotic fluid in it
like if you masturbated into the water
it you know nine months later your son
would just wash up on the shore
and he'd you know and you'd run him to
urgent care and put a couple dunkin
donuts in his bottle
[Music]
just that kind of place you know um
what else but yeah went fishing oh that
was the fun thing so went fishing
and um and they got the
they well i caught my first bass
you know and i went fishing for the
first time at five a.m in the morning
and this was crazy man we got out there
and uh
and got out there in these rowboats and
you know had some worms had some lures
or lures
and went at them
and it was uh it was
i guess you know i wish i knew more
about fishing and i'm trying to learn
more about
it you know i grew up we would just put
the it was just worm
you catch a worm or you could put a
little dog food or something on there
or a little cat food or something or one
time my buddy killed a swan and we
caught
caught a bunch of bull heads on a dam
you know on
on that swan sashimi meat you know fresh
swan
um but we got out there in the row boats
and we fished and
there was just a bunch of little just
aggravating ass fish dude a bunch of
damn water antifa
just biting at my line just nibbling at
my giblets you feel me just
thieves really looters they'd come up
steal your
steal your worm bite that [ __ ] up
and jet off go do something else they
wanted to do you know
go hit the next guy but
um but finally one spot i was on this
one bank
and i'm i was putting everything back in
anything i caught little pikes pekka
rails
um what else little bluegills
and then one time i put that i put that
bait in
and it was worm this is just ground worm
american ground worm you know
the freaking ray charles of the earth
brothers them you know
then blind bad boys you know that baby
snake you know what i'm talking about
that worm man
you know what i'm saying that
i mean a worm you know imagine being a
worm
just day after day just
just moving through dirt
and and it nothing none of it it's all
just a grind
and maybe i guess you [ __ ] other worms i
don't even know if they
do sex
i mean i've never seen them
i've never seen them doing sex worms
but i mean i
i guess if you put a couple of them in a
little cage and read them a romance
novel or something or put them in a
little
you know a bowl or something
maybe put a little bit of foil over it
you know put a little sprig of jasmine
in there and read them [ __ ] that put
a romance novel on the audible
or whatever you might hear you know
but anyway so i put that worm on there
the second it hit the water
and i've been out there about two and a
half hours three hours maybe already
the second it hit the water on this one
time i was about maybe three feet off
the bank four feet off the bank
and i'm in a little rowboat hit the
water whoosh
and man that's
you can fee immediately it's a different
feeling
and i have a tough time knowing when
like because i feel the nibble you know
i feel the
when the little ones pull on it i feel
like the little nibble
and it's hard for me to know when to set
that hook when to really just pull that
rod you know yank that that post
it's just hard for me to know and so but
this time i got it right
everything aligned and i just you know i
be honest i hooked that [ __ ]
and they call that hooking that [ __ ]
baby
ptl baby praise the lord man so it was
good bro i got one and
uh man i just i was excited
because you're talking i just come from
louisiana i didn't catch anything down
there
you know almost caught damn corvid from
uh
from freaking brendan sherlock over
there
or brendan on sherlock on sherlock
holmes that guy
dude he couldn't
you know he couldn't whatever so uh but
i got tested i got tested for corvette i
came back negative
um but i've never caught [ __ ] i've never
been that
that guy i'm not that guy
you know i'm that multi i'm multi i got
you know inside of me
i got that multi-faceted
you know i got that polish nicaraguan
dna
i got it in me and so we don't catch
that [ __ ]
i ain't i don't catch a lot of colds i
don't catch a lot of
you know
you know i might come down with a little
bit of pink eye from being naughty but
i you know i'm not that i'm not that guy
i don't catch a lot of that [ __ ]
i don't have a lot of eggs i don't have
a lot of freaking uh
you know natural scarring on my back or
anything from god or anything i don't
have any of that [ __ ]
you know knock on wood but
anyway so i caught a bass and i just
enjoyed myself up there
and i just enjoyed myself and and i was
just a third wheel
you know i was that third wheel but we
had a good time man and they were really
my friends it was just nice it was nice
to be welcome somewhere and be treated
just kindly my buddy's girlfriend is
awesome and
and it was good for me and him to catch
up and remember stuff and
you know and just remember you know who
still owes
the other one money basically um
what else what else are we getting into
man
i'm gonna tell you straight up that this
episode is brought to you by
blue chew and i don't know if you guys
remember um
you know if you guys remember the days
when you were ready to go
when you were ready to just just throw
that body lightning
and just work that dick bro you feel me
sorry to be like that but
you know i've been watching some of
these tick tocks from some of these blm
rallies dude and i'm
you know when you're ready to throw that
deck
um you remember those days right well
now you can increase your performance
and get that extra confidence in bed
that's right you can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence
in bed bluechew.com
that's blue like the color blue
blue chew brings you the first chewable
with the same fda approved
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
and you could take them anytime you know
you don't have to take them at a certain
time you can take them anytime
it could be sunrise surprise your friend
you know surprise you ladies surprise
your husband if you got if you gotta g
if you
if you're gay and your husband is also
probably gay
then surprise him get that boot get that
body
get that rocky rocky in that front
header bruh
get that knock post going you feel me
rock up that wing baby you feel me
make it deep make you deep tight
you can take them anytime day or night
even on a full stomach
you know this ain't swimming a lot of
times you can't swim on a full you got
to wait 30 minutes not with blue chew
get that [ __ ] in your system it's the
fast easy way to enhance your
sexual performance bluetooth is
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor's
office and wait in line at the pharmacy
it ships right to your door in discreet
packaging
you know they'll ship it in a unique way
they might put it in a guitar case or
something
people are always doing music but all
you're doing is freaking loading up you
know
front loading that body flute they're
made in the usa
hell yeah [ __ ] china
and since blue chew prepares and ships
direct they're cheaper than a pharmacy
and best of all there's no more
awkwardness nope
right now we got a special date deal for
our listeners visit
bluechewblueechew.com
and get your first shipment free when
you
use our special promo code theo t-h-e-o
just pay five dollars shipping again
that's b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com promo code theo to try it
for free it's the better cheaper faster
choice and we thank you
for supporting the podcast and if you
haven't tried it go support the podcast
give it a try you know i like them
i like them my first i was skeptical and
then whoo
i was not skeptical dawg you feel me
this thing you could a cat could bat
this thing around for an hour
you'll be heightened up and you got that
body height bro that [ __ ]
all right all right man i feel amped up
today
that's okay you know sometimes i get on
the podcast and i want to kind of
feel a certain way or be in a certain
mindset and
it's just it's you know
you know i always want to like plan for
life i want to be a bit okay i want it
to be this way
man it's so impossible it just comes
it's just a conveyor belt and nobody
will turn it off it keeps coming
so i gotta just send just learn to enjoy
what is on
the belt what else did i do i'm looking
through my phone
we grilled that bass up
and people sent me uh messages instant
messages
and they said don't do it boy don't need
it well
i ate it and i liked it
i like that bass meat and i'll weed it
again
i'll eat that bastard i'll tell you this
the bass had a crawfish
inside it a full body crawfish in there
living its life and doing its thing so i
guess they were like just lilo and
stitch these little m efforts bruh
because we cut right into it and a
crawdad rolled right out that bastard
and we put him back so damn
so that's that rebirth right there shout
out rebirth brass band too
oh but i've been off a coffee for a
while and now i'm trying
it again but i think i'm gonna get off
of it again
but yeah we cut this thing up i watched
some youtube tutorials
caught a picker rail over there in eaton
e-a-t-o-n new hampshire and conway
i think is the area we were in
and they had two bulldogs over there
my buddy's girlfriend had two bulldogs
and one of them has had seventy thousand
dollars worth of
physical you know or i don't know
you know different things they had to do
fix it the thing need a new spine need a
new
you know the dog can't you know it needs
a little elevator put in its hip
because it can't piss anymore so i have
to do you know
you press a button at the house and it
you know its back leg goes up and it can
relieve itself
[ __ ] all of that man dude i'm from the
where i'm from
when god wants his dog back god gets his
dog back
you got people spending 20 000 over here
get a dog a facial reconstructive
next thing you know you got a you know
you got a dog that looks like damn uh
you know you got a dog that looks like
rachel maddow or something
and that cost you 18 grand and you could
have gone another you know if you'd have
gone
28 grand you get your little juan marana
look like danny glover
or look like uh
you know um who else is somebody famous
[Music]
uh
um andre agassi
so it's just but yeah she anyway just
blew my mind the money that people will
spend on the animals i respect it i'm
not saying that this
someone aren't worth it but i'm just
saying that a certain financial
when god at a certain point you just you
paying to keep the dog from the lord
you know after you done spent 30 000 on
that pup
you know you got his they restationed
his tail and they
you know they put in two feet of pig
intestine in them
and you know it just and they had a
length in them they took part of a
wiener dog that had died in a motorcycle
accident they put it in the middle of
your dog and you just
you got that little uh you running you
know you
you got a little frankenstein this dude
[ __ ] out of his eyelids every night
and stuff before bed and you just
at a certain point it's time to give the
dog back to god
and that's where i'm from you know
that's where i'm from man
you know when i was young we used to bet
on that we used to bet on how many
babies a dog would have
you know you'd see a dog out there
whelping and you'd have somebody throw
you know like you put four dollars on
six they got six in her
you know dollar fifty let me get who who
wants dollar fifty i gotta i'll do
you know what's the over under it's
three
you know when you could do a little
parlay or something okay i hope you know
i want
five i wanna go five or over
20 and uh you know
you know 60 percent of them is going to
be females or something you can do you
know do something like that
um what else
oh lost money i bet the ufc
i should have stuck with nick my
producer nick he has the best picks
i decided to go out on my own and i lost
some money i didn't lose a lot but
actually i did lose a lot
uh i lost 400
and so i'm not happy about that i'm not
you know
it made it fun though it was something
fun to do i'm glad the ufc happens
i really am enjoying it more
uh
and usman usman is boring
dudusman is boring fighter
he's probably the most boring black guy
i've even seen do a sport
he might as well be white he might as
well be white out there
because the dude is just he's the champ
though i respect it you know i respect
her being like
you know that uh who's that guy that
would
you know the boring who would do
something great but do it boringly
um
who am i thinking of do something great
but do it boringly
um i can't think of anybody
i can but i don't know who they are um
man i'm just rambling but that's what
i'm doing today i'm rambling
um what else i watched the fights lost
some money
uh didn't catch corvid
um oh i got to see my mom when i was at
home
i got to see my nieces and nephews i
went fishing in louisiana
yeah what else man i i don't know i just
you know it was just
i don't know i don't know it's just it's
okay i'm alive the conveyor belt
is just going to keep serving up life
and that's what it is
you know i just have to be grateful that
that the belt's still going
so uh we got a couple calls that came in
uh as always the hotline is 985-664-9503
here we go hey what's up theo this is
y'all y'all from the booth and pod
um i had an interesting question what's
up y'all yo
gang bro homework interesting question
what is it
i'm about to turn 30 and i have two
months of vacation
for the first time in my adult life i'm
a middle school teacher now
and i don't know what to do with myself
oh you middle school teacher huh
well anybody could teach that dude
that's not that hard
honestly man no offense y'all but
middle school that's [ __ ] i mean that's
basically that's just
what after dinosaurs spelling that's
spelling heavy
rivers you learn in a lot of rivers and
stuff there
you know brendan would you wouldn't want
him in there or you'd have to do him
twice
you know brennan probably did all
freaking
all five grades of middle school uh
but yeah man no disrespect but middle
school's easy bro gang bro homework
especially during the corvette times i
just spent a week fishing in denver
but i was wondering uh you know since
you've had some time to yourself lately
what would you do if you had two months
off of work
no strings attached all right love you
gang
gang brother gang man love you too and
sorry whatever said earlier about your
job being easy i don't think your job is
easy i'm just saying challenge yourself
more teach them something wild
you know teach a kid how to you know
shoot a cannon or uh
you know de-bowel a boar or something
you know teach a kid how to uh you know
you know what pills are safe to take or
whatever depending on what time of day
it is you know what i'm saying
just don't be afraid to you know to kind
of loosen up the curriculum
because when [ __ ] gets hot [ __ ] gets hot
um
would you ask grandma oh what would you
do well i just realized recently i'd go
back if i could go back in time even
over the past few months i would take
more
little trips and excursions i would
spend more time
outside you know nature is wide open
right now and it's really
i feel like it's get it's a little more
well rested than ever
you know we went on a hike the other day
and um
up there in new hampshire in the hamp
and they had fresh blueberries growing
out of the ground
you know because god likes to snack
you know and um
and it was just cool they have fresh
raspberries you know
and so i was just seeing wow nature's
nature's hype
so that's what i would do nature's still
open you know some of the national parks
and stuff are closed and you got to be a
little creative but
in a lot of ways it's a great time to
get out and be a part of nature it sound
like you were doing that with the
fishing
so i think you're on track man i think
you're right on track dude
but but yeah i would just get a little
more challenging with the kid maybe have
him do stunts or something
put a bike ramp or something in the back
of the class because [ __ ] might get hot
you know teach them how to lo you know
set a trip wire
or set a snare
you know i'd love to see a middle school
class that
you know that teaches you know say of
what if what if something happens
you guys are on a field trip you guys
are going to you know the museum
if there even are museums in it you know
another couple months everything in the
museum will be
or racist and so it'll be you know
they'll shut them down but before that
you want to get in there what if the bus
crashes
and now a little davey or whatever they
gotta you know
they gotta they gotta survive they might
have to eat their buddy they might have
to
you know teach them how to do that or
something you know what i'm saying just
you know what i'm saying to see be
creative have you seen that movie school
ties
with the teacher robin williams
teaches the kids how to just
you know think for themselves man what
it's all about bro gang [ __ ]
um what else we got here
uh let's take a call man
man i don't like this caffeine it's got
me feeling all fast
onward let's go hey what's up theo
this is uh jj from denver colorado
what's up jj from denver
appreciate you calling man you know i
love denver a lot of beautiful people
over there met a beautiful woman over
there by the whole foods there
and got her number and she never
messaged me back but
that's my life baby you feel me i still
got that number
i think it was her number could have
been a fake number but at least i got
a fake number son gang baby
onward just sitting here uh listening to
this past weekend working from home
uh getting ready for a backpacking trip
to kind of get away and clear my mind
from all this crazy [ __ ] going on
good for you brother good for you man
that's beautiful homework
i was just kind of curious what your
opinion is on how people can affect
change
i know at least in denver they're having
a lot of uh mostly peaceful protests
which seems like it's working pretty
good
we have a police reform coming up soon
and i'm just curious if you think that
voting is the only way to affect change
or
or kind of what you think would be the
best way to go about that because it
seems like
a lot of people are hurting and they're
trying to get things changed but no
one's really listening to them
gang bro thank you for the call you know
what's interesting man
you know i find that the biggest
effector of changes really is time
um and you know you can't just depend on
time
you know you have to remind time of what
you want
and i think you see a lot of that
recently with you know a lot of the
protests a lot of
you know you see a lot of it
you know just to you know remind for
people to
share what they feel and get out there
and
share what their feelings are um
so yeah i think that that kind of stuff
is good i think voting for people that
you know yeah that you know support the
things you want
um
but it's hard i think the biggest things
that we can do because look i want to
get the the place not to do it is
arguing online
it just it doesn't it that you can't win
you know i got in a you know i usually
do a good job of not doing it and then
the other day i commented on something
on my social media and um
and it just you know sometimes you just
you know you want to it's weird because
sometimes you feel online in
in social media you feel you know people
behave
ways online that they're not really
behaving in real life which is
interesting
and i might be going off topic i don't
even know exactly what i'm talking about
but
um but i find it saying
and i'll do the same it's like would i
really go off on somebody or
you know
um i think some of the stuff is good i
think some of it though like people
start to use
uh you know like i think reminding
people
of diversity in that you know the
diversity is important
you know if if you're talking about the
black live matter rallies and stuff that
that stuff
it's important is super important you
know
i think i think some of the reform for
police departments is good
i think i like the idea of there being
if there are people that have mental
health issues
you don't that the police aren't the
ones that have to deal with it
man i feel bad a lot of times when i see
police officers and i see this all the
time
in los angeles police officers having to
deal with
homeless people and people who are
mentally unwell
because it's just a lot of pressure on
on cops
you know and the way that they're
trained a lot of their training is
probably more
in tactical combatical type training
and so even just seeing them having to
spend their time doing it you can tell a
lot of times the officers want to you
know they want to
help be helpful but to if they could
spend you know they could probably
definitely better spend that time
elsewhere and not have as much stress
so that kind of stuff i like um
so yeah i think some of those things are
good you know i think you're gonna see
good come out of these types of things
um i think you also see bad come out of
these types of things you see people
you know trying to
i don't know man you see people trying
to where it's not about equality some
people want to make it about control
you know i feel like a lot of times i
felt attacked just as a white person in
the past
month really um
you know i don't support any type of
supremacy that's what i don't support i
don't support
you know white supremacy black supremacy
jewish supremacy
you know iranian supreme i don't support
any
uh that kind of stuff when people are
trying to control you
you know that's when people start to
make things about themselves
um and it's not about a conversation
it's just about them
people controlling you that's the part
that gets that doesn't affect i feel
like that just creates
animosity um
but i like i like the way that your
handling is man to go and spend some
time
you know taking a break uh
because i think in the end still the way
that we can best affect
change is we can affect it within
ourselves
um and then we can
affect it you know help affect it in and
be a part of
the loved ones around us you know but
really it's in ourselves
because it's hard to make somebody do
anything you really can't
and so you just do you know you affect
it within yourselves
um it's the same thing i think about the
masks a lot of times
you know people say you're not people
aren't wearing mat well that's it that
you can't control that what you can
control is if you wear a mask
that's why i say you know just
just that fight though going for the
fight somebody
you know we just get caught up in
fighting and that's that kind of stuff
is
it's just not helpful to us and i don't
think it generally it makes anybody feel
good
i also think that you should have to
have a
some type of
i don't know if it's education or
or degree i don't know if degree
wouldn't really be fair
i don't know what it should be to have
social media
um but that's a whole different topic
and maybe that's a bad idea you know i
don't know
uh but anyway man i like what you're
doing man going out there and affecting
yourself that's all we can really do
um you know and sometimes i think a lot
of the
the stuff that's been going on it's not
hell it's not helpful
you know i'll have a friends that are
you know of both races who are suddenly
activists
and that's bizarre to me like
they're angrier than usual
and that's you know i i don't know if
that's
i i don't know it just seems that like
that's not good
you know it's like well you weren't an
activist before you
just you know and that's scary when i
start to even find myself i'm
becoming like an activist like i
understand standing up for yourself and
just sharing what you what you're
feeling and thinking
i don't know it's interesting man
there's a lot going on
but in the end for me the only the only
real way i know it'll probably affect
change is to just
try to affect it within myself uh and
affect how i'm reacting to the
environment
that's around me um and yeah and to vote
um and to work hard
oh so those are things man those are
things that i'm just thinking about and
none of that is
you know i'm not trying to say i know
anything
um because that's that is the last thing
i'm trying to say
that i know anything but i'm just trying
to share what i'm kind of feeling man
um i do want to tell you about this
though that today's episode is brought
to you
by
[Music]
you guessed it manscaped you know and
it's really
now that's one thing you need to do
effect change on your body
make sure your penis looks nice or your
vagina you know
make sure you're vagistic make sure that
area looks
classy trim around your nipples a lot of
men grow long
you know they got them rapunzel's around
them nip around them nipples you know
like you like your titties trying to
pull somebody up to it
trim that up you know summer even though
we don't notice it really because we're
trapped summer is in full action and
we're thankful for our sponsor today
manscaped for keeping us fresh
sun's out bums out and hopefully your
pubic hair is not out and showing
it's not that time of year
you know uh i've had a time where i was
you know i grew up in the
you know i grew up in the i i grew up
probably a couple hundred years after
the industrial revolution
and we didn't have manscape back then so
you had to you had to take the hair that
was on your body around your crotch you
had to pull it stretch it from your body
and trim it like that
that old school you know really just
something you'd see uh i don't know
where you'd see it
but when you saw it you wouldn't like it
that kind of
that kind of tactic but that's over
you know because you might nick your
nuts you might trim any aside of your uh
your [ __ ] but actually manscape has just
released their shears 2.0
nail kit which is the perfect add-on to
their lawnmower
3.0 or perfect package
the shears 2.0 is a luxury four-piece
nail kit
featuring tempered stainless steel tools
and it includes
slashed tipped tweezers rounded point
scissors
fingernail clippers and a medium grit
nail file
you're probably wearing flip-flops and
people don't want to see those nasty
unclipped
toes of yours they don't have to don't
show your dirty feet to people
don't show your nasty hands to people
take care of your body trim your body
clip your body
do it right and for a limited time
our subscribers get two free gifts the
shed
travel bag a 40 value
and the patented high performance
reduced chafing
manscaped boxer briefs a beautiful pair
get 20 off and free shipping with code
theo t-h-e-o at manscaped.com
theo that's right support the podcast
guys we need the support
we want to stay in business get 20 off
and free shipping with code theo
t-h-e-o at manscaped.com
theo that's free shipping
20 off theo at manscape.com theo summer
is here it's time to manscape
man this thing's got me heightened up
yeah the fights were great though i
enjoyed watching the fights
i'm going to tell you also what you need
to know is
this that this is one extra one extra i
got to tell you about this that
you know i was having some credit
problems i've been trying to get a
refinance
um you know i have an apartment in
louisiana
and it i got a bad loan on it
and my credit has not been good and so
i'll try to get a refinance and they
said
when i tried that my credit has two
dings on it it has
you know i didn't have a i missed a loan
payment on my mortgage there
and something else credit issue
so um i got recommended by my friend
to bridge credit solutions
and now i'm working with them uh to
solve
my credit problems so that i don't have
to wait
the nine months or six months or
whatever it is
of clear clean credit you can get the
dings
removed from your credit and that's what
bridge credit solutions is doing for me
and they are different because they are
backed with a hundred percent
money back guarantee for any items that
cannot be removed
you will not find that anywhere in the
credit repair industry
you know exactly what you're paying for
at the beginning of the repair
no open-ended monthly fees it's written
in the contract what work is to be done
and how much you're paying if they do
the work
then you pay and if they don't do the
work you get your money back
now you will need to have bridge report
access prior to scheduling your audit
we cannot go over your credit report
without this
and the bridge report access costs just
one
dollar you can find all of this on
bridgecreditsolutions.com
t-h-e-o they also specialize in helping
with other financial needs
zero percent apr loans business loans
financial counseling credit monitoring
and debt consolidation
bridge credit solutions dot com
slash t-h-e-o
and they are legit that's what i want to
tell you is that they are legit
uh i'm working with them right now um
and the items that can't be removed i'm
not gonna pay for
and you can't find that anywhere in the
credit repair industry
so check them out what else do we got
man
sorry i feel like there was something i
was going to tell you about but um
anyway let's get another call or two man
here we go
gang rat kane what's up man this is
clint campbell aka murder
what's up murder and that's a risky name
you got man but i respect it
you know it's risky if if you go to
court it's risky
but if you go into a bar and people
looking at you funny dude then it's
you know it's more unrisky then onward
starving mississippi
me and my wife just wanted to give you a
call man let's let you know we love you
we with you man i know everything's
crazy out there
just keep your head up man we love you
from mississippi
gang gang bro gang man thanks man that
was nice of you dude
it's nice you to say that and to include
your wife and um
yeah you know and people need to hear
that sometimes man people need to hear
that people are thinking about them and
i got a lot of nice calls this past two
weeks you know
i know it's been a few weeks since i did
a episode just solo
and i'm gonna start doing those more
often you know i just needed a break
over time
um you know when i've been trying to
adjust my diet and
you know uh because this blood work i
got i was not doing well
and i was not doing well i had vitamin
deficiencies they call it
you know low stuff in you
you know if god look at you know looked
up under the hood he said damn you
missing some [ __ ] i put in here
and so you know i'm trying to
get that get my health back and it takes
a while
that kind of stuff takes a while um
you know what some of this has been nice
uh you know uh
during this virus time
you know it's been nice to have some
reflection
[Music]
um you know it definitely
i will say one thing about being on a
plane flying on a plane everybody has to
wear a mask
now and it's quiet on the plane
and man that's nice it's so nice
there's no everybody's quiet it's
put the mat it's quiet now i don't think
it's good for us as humans long-term or
anything like that
but it's quiet
you know it's been nice to have some
time to reflect i've gotten i've been
able to talk with friends recently
that i just
you know and stop over by friends houses
and just spend time with people
you know and that's been nice just to
slow it down
you know to get out into nature some and
realize oh i like it out here
i forgot this was an option i got caught
up in
in this rat race you know and caught up
in a game that i don't even know
i didn't even say i told i never even
signed up for the game
it's just you get going and you get into
college and you feel like you got to
get the job and then you gotta and you
have to support yourself you have to be
working but
just this insatiable thing of more
that's what i've been on kind of i've
been on that
you know i've been
i've just been on that um
but love you too man i love you guys too
man i know starkville
and shout out my friend tj malweny i
went and saw him one down there
and he uh used to play football down
there at mississippi state
gang brother let's take another call
here 985-664-9500
hi theo i'm calling from toronto canada
and with everything going on i've been
out of work
for four months now and
i'm kind of running out of money at this
point
but i also feel more
calm than i felt in a really long time
which is very bizarre
so my question to you is
do you think it's better to be broke and
happy
or rich and miserable
i think there's more options than that i
appreciate the call i think there's more
options than that
i think you can be wealthy and be happy
um
i think you can be poor and be happy
you know some of the most beautiful
smiles i've ever seen have been in
foreign countries of just full poverty
you know complete poverty i'm talking
somebody you know people drinking out of
each other's penises really
real you know you got to be thirsty to
cut that faucet on you feel me
and
but the happiest people you know
the happiest people um so i think
there's ways to do it i do think
you know i do think there's been a
i think there's too much infatuation on
the bottom line for companies and and
businesses and business owners
you know i think you want to do well but
also remembering the value of your
employees and of people you work with
and that you want them to do well too
um so i think there's a better way to be
to do wealth and to do
you know not making money your god
i think there's a better way to do it
than the way that we've been doing it
and i think that a lot of that change
has to come from within people
um and i think there's a thing of too
wealthy i think at a certain point some
people don't need to be that wealthy
i don't think that i i believe in
meritocracy i believe in people working
hard and
and that's how you earn wealth and
that's what you do you know i believe in
the hard work that pays off
i believe in that
but i also believe at a certain point
you know there should be creative ways
to give back
now some people you want them to have
the wealth
you know like people different you know
people who run big companies like um
you know what's a big company craft mac
and cheese
you know you want certain people the
money to go to you know you want them to
because they're going to create jobs for
other people
you know if the money goes to freaking
uh ronald craft
he ain't doing [ __ ] he might be shooting
up over there
by the airport or by graham
and shout out we're going to do i got
some greyhound calls that came in i'm
going to get to them uh
later in the week but
but you know bob craft the money goes to
him he's going to you know some people
you need the money to go through them
because they're creators they're going
to create
employment for the tens and thousands of
people
but sometimes i feel like there should
be a cap on how much money you can have
as a human
so there'd be more money for other
people to get but i think lifting people
you work for
up you know and helping them be
you know excited about the money that
you know people working towards a
company and
you know um i think that stuff's
important
people oh i work for a company i'm
prideful in because i'm gonna make money
as well the boss
they're not always trying to just keep
me at this one space and not
reward my efforts
and i hope we'll see some of that too on
a national scale you know
maybe i'm being too political in some of
this episode but
um if we have more jobs back in the us
you know
just because there's a there's just a
there's a bigger value in a lot of
things than
just than the value of the money of it
um
but there's a special fund man of not
having
of not having uh anything
man there's a special type of joy of
having nothing
say [ __ ] them bruh you know
because nobody can take nothing away
from you then
man and that is a that is a freedom
nobody can take nothing but he's trying
to take and nobody expect you got the uh
you are the underdog nobody expects it
so when you show up and you deliver bruh
there's no
there's nothing that feels better
man i've been right there man i've been
right there most of my life
honestly i'm saying all right you don't
expect okay
oh i can't huh and not even an
individual person's
not telling you can't just the way the
system is
the way it's all set up they don't
expect
you
and you show up and you that baby danger
and you that baby danger boy gang [ __ ]
man
uh let's hear what's what else man we
got some other calls that came in
yo theo it's cj from ohio man and i uh
what's up cj thanks for the call bud
just calling checking with directing
himself see how you're doing uh
news going on now with uh with chris and
stuff just checking in on you
yeah and he's referencing um you know
crystalline the
the stuff that some of these calls were
a couple weeks haven't done a regular
episode
um onward i don't know how close you
guys are and it's gotta be tough man
um but uh appreciate everything you do
on the podcast and help people out it's
awesome
uh going through some stuff myself man
just it's hard to see
like everyone says oh it works out in
the end and it's
everything ends up the way it should be
it's just hard to see that man going
through a divorce and
moving in with my mom you know at like
30 years old it's just like
god like look like i'm thankful i have
that to move into it's just scary to
for that next step man and just i got
school loans and just a lot of stuff
there's stuff going on man
it's it's cool that uh to hear all the
positive good stuff you're doing and
um i don't man just get look for some
positivity
gang bro thanks for the call man um
you know i appreciate you know uh i
appreciate your sentiment yeah just
thinking about me and just thinking
about chris you know
um you know i need to message him and
just uh
just let him know that i'm thinking
about him um
you know i think you have a you know a
nice opportunity here man
you know i know it's probably got to be
tough and it's got to be a real
u-turn in your dreams to be
back in with mom and you over there and
y'all splitting the lasagna and doing
that
and now you watching the [ __ ] you guys
are you know suddenly all applying for
the mother-son prices right weekend or
whatever doing all of that [ __ ]
i feel you bro you know suddenly
you know you're stuck watching a this is
us marathon witter i feel you
i feel you're in that um
and it's gonna be hard you probably have
to listen to your mom and
and do a lot of that uh
you know i just challenge you man there
were times where i had to go back into
things like that
you know i even remember about eight
years ago i you know i i went back to
louisiana and i was working at a
bartender
and i just didn't know man i didn't know
if comedy was for me i didn't know what
i wanted you know
uh you know i moved for a relationship i
was in a rough relationship i shouldn't
have been in i didn't even like this
girl
but i was in it and um
and i wish i had to handle myself better
then just looking back
you know it'll be hard but just you know
just do your best man try to be loving
maybe learn a new card game or something
and play with your mom or
because i think you're you know it's you
sound like a guy that's still going to
achieve his dreams and his goals
but i know that's a lot at one time with
the
relationship and maybe god's given you
that relationship with your mom you know
and y'all can't have sex but y'all could
do everything else man
you know not you know i mean you could
kiss but just real quick
you know nothing you can't do everything
but you could just kiss fast you know
just like a regular good night
you know kind of thing um
but it could just be you know i know
it's gonna be hard to see that i know
i'm preaching you know
but it's gonna be okay bro it's gonna be
okay
you know i would just if you could if
you can it's gonna be hard
try to manage yourself the best you can
while you're going through this
i don't want you to look back on it and
be like damn
you know i had this opportunity
to spend time with my mother to be a
part you know to try and help her to do
and i
saw it as a as a
liability you know
but but again man i'm preaching and [ __ ]
bro but
best of luck man keep your head up and
learn gin rummy bruh michigan rummy
those are some good ones i learned
recently
uh scrabble i haven't seen this is us
but my brother and his wife absolutely
love it man
um and it's probably a good time to
watch it you know i know it has it deals
with a lot of racial stuff and so maybe
it's a good time to
you know just to see people you know
beige power man you know
this is all going to end beige so it'd
be a good time to
see some of that gang [ __ ] peace
um here we go man another call
hey theo just uh i'm looking at reading
an
article in the los angeles times about
the crystalline situation
and i see why you uh have so much
trouble with the media
and like how they portray things and how
they twist stuff i mean
the los angeles times is supposed to be
you know during this
pandemic and all this stuff supposed to
be like the source of
you know well-edited well-researched
you know good news they have they're
taking quotes from the
king this thing like as law
of what is happening in light of what
ever chris did and i just feel like
that's such [ __ ] that they like
would try to use that information
from a podcast like from king in this
thing like a comedy podcast and try to
rope you into all this and someone who
knew something so
i see why you have your feelings about
the media i guess i'm just curious in
this time
you know what who you feel you're able
to listen to and
who you feel uh is giving you
information that's positive
or um you know something that you can
feel like is factual or well researched
or bipartisan all that
nonsense gang bro i appreciate that call
man
um yeah and again some of these calls
are a couple weeks back and
uh i'm not trying to rehash old stuff or
anything but
yeah you know yeah los angeles time did
an article and they
you know people online there was a this
older lady who used to be a comedian
and you know she was calling out clips
from king and the sting
you know um and
just cr just yeah i mean just
yeah the the the reliability
of a lot of
journalism is ratchet
i mean it's like graffiti on walls it's
like just believe you know
you read larry sucks dick and then you
believe it
well you know do we who do you we even
know where larry is
is he in the community where is he you
know
who is it who's he what is it you know
is it
have anybody seen him you know it just
it's like believing graffiti
um so i'm not shocked man you know i'm
just i'm not shocked but when you see
that stuff start to come and you see
your name in it yeah that kind of stuff
gets
uncomfortable because you're like this
is supposed to be credible
the sources there's people are citing
just
unbelievable sources for everything
you know and it's new it's weird with
news because you don't want the
government to control the news
but the media has so much power
just by the sheer volume
and the scope of it that
they can cause a lot of trouble
you know a lot more i think a lot more
people have social
and um a lot more people have issues
online than they do in real life
you know it's just giving us so it's
just it's the news has just gotten it's
gotten
unreliable and some people some of the
smartest people i know
believe us everything on the news
and to me that is just baffling
it's almost like they want to
and i notice it for myself if i'm going
to the news if i'm going to these
articles and i'm going to just see all
the headlines
i want that
you know i'm wanting that sort of i'm
i'm looking for that food that
that whatever that
it's junk food i know it is
i'm looking for an excuse to be angry
i'm looking for i'm looking for it
so it's really it starts with us man
it's it's
so where do i get good stuff from i
think i just communicate directly with
people see
and see what's going on you know i do
think it's a time where
um you have to trust your instincts
um but i don't know where there's a good
source for news
you know i i believe this i don't trust
hollywood
and i believe hollywood does this they
build you up
you can if you want to be in the system
you can get built up
you know when you pay for that along the
way you know you pay agents you pay
uh what is it called um
per uh public relation people
that sort of thing publicist that sort
of thing and i'm not saying these are
bad people i'm just saying
this is the system that i view sometimes
and i might have a negative view of the
system
i understand that they build you up but
then
at a certain point they also then then
articles come
that that tear you down and now some of
it can be based on your own behavior i'm
not saying people's behaviors don't
influence it
they tear you down and then now you got
to pay lawyers so all the money you made
you got to pay the lawyers
and then you're done so it's just this
dirty hill man
it's this dirty hill but it's risky man
it's risky um
so i don't know i don't know the answer
to it but i know it doesn't make me feel
that good when i'm
when i'm when i'm around it and i know i
try and be careful with my career that i
don't it's just scary bro it's scary to
be a part of something that can do that
um let's take another call that came
in right here man we got to finish this
episode up man thank you guys for being
uh
part of this sorry if i you know maybe i
have too much political stuff i'm not
really a pilot i'll just
you know i know it's a tough time for a
lot of people
i know it is i know it feels scary right
now
um
but it's also there's spaces in places
where it's not
and we gotta find those man gang all
right
kenny wanna thank you for sharing this
week
man i really appreciate it
i guess my thoughts are that
you know people are a duality man
everyone's a good and bad nobody's good
or bad
man you know it's sometimes you do good
things and sometimes you do bad things
and
it doesn't make you good or bad and you
don't you don't you don't make them good
i don't know man you just
i appreciate you being real
you know you can be real even if you
can't
be good or bad you can decide to be real
you can be honest
gang man i appreciate the call man uh we
can try you know i try
you know i mean i make so you know we
all do yeah we're
that's what i don't that's what's tough
for me is like how do we quit seeing
that people are
people we're human
they we do good stuff we do wrong stuff
you know you could give a dollar to a
baby and then still also
you know you know go touch your
neighbor's wife's b-hole or something
and be naughty and be that you know
we're just people
um
we're just people and some days we do it
right and some days we do it wrong some
moments we do it right some moments we
do it wrong
yeah we really are dog
but that conveyor belt it keeps serving
it bro keep serving more you know
whatever it is life keeps coming in
um but whoever you are man i'm glad you
know that
you know we don't you know none of us
when none of us are
you know it's just uh we just we try
maybe you just got to keep trying
you know but we good man everybody's all
right dude
if you get up there to frickin maine get
up there to new hampshire you need
urgent care bruh
you cut you got a [ __ ] crab net stuck
in your sphincter dog don't worry
don't even forget about it dude
in a heartbeat i'll dude i'll put a
[ __ ]
i'll cut your stomach open and fill it
with crawlers but i don't have to
swallow
you know i put two bavarian glazed up in
that bastard
i put two chocolate cream filled a
couple long johns in you
you'll be fine dude
you dislocated your wrist bro don't
forget about it i'll glaze that [ __ ]
you feel me i'll glaze that [ __ ] over
by the duncan you're gonna be fine bruh
throw a couple donuts on that [ __ ] son
um what else i i wanted
i want to take one more call that gets
us out of here on something cool bro
um
oh let me see what we got here here we
go man this was a call came in a couple
weeks ago this is
this is talking about that gang [ __ ] hey
this is james calling you from uh north
of your borders
way up in canada here welcome welcome to
america uh
verbally and audibly gang saskatchewan
this is kind of like the uh the dakotas
and oklahoma all smashed together of i
don't know if you ever been up here to
saskatchewan but
oh yeah i've been up there dude a guy
tried to give me a hat one time and also
i thought the guy was also um
you know uh pedophile and i told him i
said i'm an adult
i think he had me i think i just looked
young at the time and it was uh
and it was real snowy out and so he
pulled over to talk to me i just yelled
nah nah nah i keep going man i'm an
adult and he [ __ ] left man so
onward i kind of said it in your accent
to begin with because i'm watching your
podcast so there you are anyways theo i
i just seen a moment you had there where
you got a call and it
cracked you a little bit and it just
kind of let off that same thing for me
in my heart and it was just due to you
and your reaction
and at first i didn't think nothing of
that call and then i saw the way you
reacted to it and then it you know
through you it stuck
struck through to me and i've been
drinking a little heavily in my own
regard and it was that call about the
man who's gets over
been sober for a year and uh
in my life it's been about six years
since i lost somebody close to me this
is the first year
where i'm starting to feel a little bit
all right so
a little thing like that it's a nice
little push pushing my uh
subconscious when you feel that little
frog in your throat
when you see your boy theo crack up you
crack up yourself and you start to think
about the picture a little bit bigger
and uh thank you for everything you do
sir you're the best man keep her going
oh gang bro i'm not the best man but
that's sweet of you to say man
um yeah you know it's it's magical man
how
how that kind of stuff happens man when
people make you kind of feel something
because yeah the guy called he got a
year or a couple years his girlfriend
gave him the coin to congratulate him
for his you know for not drinking and he
didn't think that she noticed and then
she did notice and
yeah that you know it had me cracked up
um
um yeah you know and it's
and it's powerful it's not and it has
nothing to do with me man and i
appreciate you
the call you know and uh and i'm glad
you're feeling better about your friend
passing and
um or at least getting some peace from
it uh
but there's that's there's something you
know there's some other wavelength where
we all
connect because that's crazy man that
that guy left a voicemail
on a machine a human voice
and i listened to it a week later
and had a had a visceral reaction to it
you know that made me feel something
that [ __ ] [ __ ] lightning in my damn
heart
you know like a [ __ ] fat animal just
eating chocolates in my heart that [ __ ]
had me
you know just have me feeling
and and then you hear it and then you
feel
it's just i don't know man there's just
a greater that and that power whatever
that that
that wavelength whatever that is bro
that's you know that's that spice man
that's you know that's that gas station
dick pill from god
you know that's the thing that that's
power it's powerful
and i and look man i'm just part of the
chain you're part of the chain now
uh
and i you know i don't know i just
there's something about feeling there's
something about
hearing how people feel that i i like
it
um i like it man
i think you know i don't know
it's interesting man
it's interesting but thanks for the call
man and
actually i talked to that that fell on
the phone the other day and we had a
nice chat
and uh and
and you know we just keep going the
conveyor belt keeps going we're on this
[ __ ]
you know hug somebody move in with your
mother
help her recycle do the [ __ ]
you know understand that people are
people
you know we just we keep trying support
you know if somebody's struggling you
know try and support them
we do what we can we're not perfect man
you know and look i'll be honest dude
i've been jerking off bruh
and i'm disappointed about it
you know i didn't think i was going to
be jerking off and then bam
i'm touching my body and leaking my
wiener out
you know with uh
um
with semen you know and making semen out
of
you know just it just
we do what we can bro
but the time keeps going man time is no
stranger
that is for sure isn't it we'll play the
song one more time this is uh
stevie starlight off his new album
unnaturally happy
time is no stranger
and we got new gang gang slides
available
um we got the new website you can check
out
theovan.com um
great ways to submit uh video and audio
for the show
um and
you know be good to yourself you know
you probably deserve it
you know i bet you really do uh
gang [ __ ] man peace
[Music]
there's nothing left to see
someone tv
[Music]
told me to be patient
love will find its way
wait and see
[Music]
look what's happened to me
by yourself
there's no damn job
someone else
[Music]
[Applause]
too
[Music]
there you go and you can get that again
that's stevie's starlight and you can
support that man he's uh
uh it's never too late
to come over remember that hit we've
we've had it as part of the you know
part of the program for
for a long time and um steve is a
beautiful man
and uh and he's always
he's always right on time man and we'll
have a link to his new album
uh unnaturally happy and uh
again be good to yourself man i'm gonna
try my best you try your best
and i will do it again soon we'll run it
back gang